i welcome those who have just joined we
may begin
and um more five to ten minutes waiting
for others to join as well thank you
so while we wait for others to join it
would be really great if you all
could tell us about your uh background
from whatever fields are you coming and
also about your research interests
so i see new people joining us today
uh hi nadia hi pooja
zahara you are from one of our uh
programs right from the for the chem
informatics
one yes i am
at the program it's good to have you
here with us today
thank you so much hi pankaj
it would be great if you tell me about
your
background and your research interest in
the chat box
so that we know we have people from
which all faiths
thank you
we are live on youtube and i have shared
the link so if any one of you misses out
on the zoom meeting you all can watch
the
uh meeting over youtube as well
i'll share the link again for those who
have just joined
here is the link thank you
looks like you're on mute
oh i'm so sorry yes so i was saying that
we will be starting in more five minutes
thank you for joining
hi dr awake it's good to have you with
us today
you would want to know about your
research and trust
and also your background you come from
which field
it would be great if you let us know in
the chat box thank you
okay we have someone by the name of king
[Music]
hi king hi hina
hi king it's good to have you with us
okay so you are a public health
microbiologist that's
interesting thanks for sharing
thank you everyone for joining i think
we should begin now while
others can join midway so welcoming you
all to today's webinar on covet 19
genomics and variant
program we would
okay i'm so sorry so in this program we
will learn about the ways the sas scope
to pandemic has transformed our
appreciation of genomics and
bioinformatics
and understand how genomic data analysis
tools can help identify specific
vial strains and understand multiple
sequence alignment
phytogenetic analysis and the
significance of mutations
in the context of protein structure and
function my name is sunalika
ray and i'm the omixlogic community
manager
and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a bioinformatics community
which is managed by fine biotech so
before
we start with the talk i would want to
introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators
to develop easy to use analytical tools
and our mission is to make
bioinformatics more accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration
between prime biotech and numerous
academic institutions
that have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review
and project design and i'm honored to
have been working with a team
that has collectively an amazing
experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company dr alfred trauber who comes from
a medical background with an expertise
in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information
and one of the major projects of his is
the establishment of double
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brotzky is the director of
trouble bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platf form is a result of hard work
by some of the people mentioned here on
the right
julia panna who was an expert
bioinformatician and has
helped prepare many of the materials
that we would use
avi tatovsky who is a computer scientist
and
also is an expert who develops the who
developed the tbio info platform that we
would be using
dr harpreet has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques on biomedical data
and the development of prediction tools
and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science
course development dr mohit mazumdar is
an experienced buy information
with multiple publications in
peer-reviewed journals and
collaborations in industry and academia
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead
for omix logic training and research
fellowship
now i would like to pass it on to ceo
find biotech ilia broski to take the
session ahead
thank you very much tonight and welcome
everyone to
the program i'm going to share my screen
and briefly introduce
the program itself
so as you know the surveillance
of stars cove 2 and specifically
variance of concern is an ongoing effort
that is
critical to the successful strategy that
will help
overcome challenges related to
vaccination
related to other factors that contribute
to the emergence
of novel variants and to the ways that
these could be addressed with prevention
treatment
vaccination and other types of measures
so what we wanted to do in this program
is to introduce all of the participants
to data repositories
how to effectively use them including
repositories like ncbi
virus and gis aid where millions of
sequences from around the world
have been shared just in the context of
this pandemic but
importantly the rate of submission is
continuing to grow
and we'll talk a lot more about what
kind of data
and how to find the right kind of data
relevant kind of data to structure a
bioinformatics project
but we also will talk about some of the
analysis tools
that help us translate this data to
information that is relevant
so what kind of methods are we going to
be talking about we're going to be
talking about sequence alignment
gene expression studies how to analyze
the immune responses
to the infection how to organize our
data
in a phylogenetic treaty and use
molecular clock to kind of
understand the timing that helps us
establish
some difference between sequences or
groups of sequences
we'll talk about structural biology how
we can map these variants
onto the structure of the critical
proteins like the spike protein
and we'll talk about variant calling how
in all of this
data that comes from different sources
with different methods of sequencing
different depth of sequencing
how can we extract confidently that
specific variants
that are of interest and then we'll also
talk about how to utilize these
methods using the t bioinfo platform
which allows for
a seamless end-to-end processing
visualization
and analysis of sequencing data but also
how to use
r to then prepare reporting on the
identified variation and how to look at
those reports
following some examples of industry
standards that are being used
by teams around the world that are
continuously engaged in this
effort of monitoring the emerging
variants and the
development of variation in this virus
so here you can see on ncbi how
ncbi right before the pandemic or maybe
even during the
pandemic has updated this interface for
ncbi virus makes it very easy
to find specific sequences so we'll
actually go and do some hands-on
exercises
to find sequences from different animals
from different time points
compared different source cove one and
two
variants or sorry genomes and how to
then track the progression in time so
it's a very useful interface
and then down here below you can also
see some recent statistics on the number
of
uh sequences genomic sequences that have
been submitted for
the novel coronavirus so really a huge
repository that all of us have access to
and we'll talk about how to gain access
how to know how to filter and find
specific types of data that you need
and then how to also structure your
bioinformatics research question
using this information and perhaps talk
to you about the
questions you might already have and
think through how can we
organize that and translate that into a
technical sequence
of steps that you can follow to actually
get reliable
and meaningful results from this
information so the important
outcomes for this program is to study
trends behind the emergence of source
code two variants
we'll talk about the emergence of the
virus the infection itself where did it
come from
and how do we know where it could have
come from we're not going to be
addressing any
kind of speculation about where we can
know
the specific location of the emergence
of the time of the emergence but we'll
talk about
how do we use genomic data to know
the source to identify a common ancestor
we'll talk about genomic surveillance
what does genomic surveillance mean
how is data collected different types of
sequencing technologies different types
of
bioinformatics analysis methods we'll
talk about downstream analysis of
genomic data so how we can
use information from genomic data sets
to
understand phylogeny or evolution how do
we
track origin and how do we report
accurately
the type of analysis that we've done
we'll talk about
creating a report on genomic sequencing
data using cloud processing in a custom
r script so i'll talk a little bit more
about that in a few minutes
and we'll talk about future directions
for these large-scale vaccination
efforts and variant of concern
monitoring so where is it going
what are some of the factors that we
should be mindful of
as we track the emergence of existing
and novel variants of concern and some
ideas about
classification why it's an important
effort so
to start it off i want to briefly
kind of go back to where we came from
how did we actually get to this point of
knowing that there are many different
variants and many different variants of
concern and what's the difference
so as you can see here probably most of
you are already familiar with this type
of visualization this is
a phylogenetic tree that shows us how
over time on the x-axis we see emergence
of different groups
that right here are already colored by
their
phylogenetic taxonomy so these are the
different
names of strains and you can see down at
the bottom the proportion of these
strains
in the worldwide population so we
originally
have been introduced already to this
idea that genomic data
can provide us with a time series
type of analysis that demonstrates how
variants of concern have changed in
proportion of
infected cases now there are many issues
around
this specific type of reporting from a
data perspective
of course there's the sampling rate
there are the specific
methods that have been used to determine
association with different taxonomic
units and so that is why essentially it
is very critical
to look at this data and look at this
type of reporting
with in-depth understanding so for
example here you can see
how the number of types of clades
that have been reported is growing
over the course of this pandemic from
three
then to five to then eight and then to
ten and so
that number will continue to grow
and the specific proportions here are
important as well so you can see that
some
are completely going to disappear over
time some are going to emerge and become
completely new
and so over time the dynamic of
emergence and reappearance of some of
these variants is called
phylodynamics so this is a phylodynamic
vu
of this source cov2 phylogeny so we
conduct a phylogenetic analysis we look
at
genomic variation and then we include
the component of time
so really the objective of this analysis
is to try to identify
the factors that drive this variation as
it emerges
as it emerges across time and so because
of the availability of
data and because of this universal
approach to taxonomic classification we
now
can look specifically at each type of
variant
to understand how they individually
develop over time so what you can see
here are the specific variants
that have a proportion by country
and you can see that most of the
countries are going up but
not in a linear and not in a uniform
fashion
so you can see that there's a lot of
variation by region and country
you can also see the specific mutations
that define
a particular clade or a strain so here
you can see
specific variants of concern down at the
bottom the famous ones like the uk
south africa and brazil and you can also
see
how these mutations are mapped onto 3d
structures so
all of this information is widely
accessible
and i think what is the major point
is for us to be able to track
the data as it emerges and to be able to
apply these meaningful
analytical techniques to gain a better
understanding of the biology behind the
individual variants
to understand the complexity of this
taxonomic classification
and then to be able to sample new data
that is coming out
and find relevant information in this
new data that we can make decisions
based on so what's important is
obviously to also
think about these new developments and
all of us have been hearing
not so long ago this novel delta variant
emerged in england or sorry in india not
so far ago and not so long ago
and this new delta variant the b1617.2
uh how it has been growing tremendously
i think by june
has accounted for about 70 of all the
new infections
so it's a major concern especially
because
the vaccine effectiveness against this
new delta variant
seems to be incomplete so it does not
offer
a hundred percent or even a 95 as
originally was tested
for pfizer for astrazeneca even lower 60
effective remember that fda approval is
after typically 70
so really major challenges to these
standard approaches to one type of a
vaccine
and needing the additional effort to
really understand
the phylodynamics how is this strain
going to continue to evolve
are there new strains that are going to
be added on to this b16172
so importantly if we go back to this
slide
you can see that major mutations
non-synonymous as well as synonymous are
not
unique for each string in fact all of
these defining mutations
overlap in many cases between the
individual
uh strains that are reported for example
you can even see in the naming b
1 1 7 b one three five one right so
the b was one of the original clays that
separated from the a clade
and so as we continue accumulation of
novel mutations means that this is not a
completely new strain it's really
additional numbers of mutations that we
need to
understand their impact collectively
on this effort to address the problem
with vaccines
not only that important new changes to
this new strain
is that it affects much more
significantly the younger population
which was not true for their original
strain
it also tends to be a problem for people
that have
one or even two shots of the vaccine and
it is spreading much faster so there are
additional
challenges that we should be
anticipating as this process continues
but to really
study this problem or this challenge in
detail
i think we need to go back understand
the biology
behind source code ii the infection
itself
the rate of transmission as well as the
evolutionary changes that are starting
to appear in the genome
and to understand this biology at the
level
of reporting so that we can accurately
look and sample at data
and we can start asking questions about
these individual mutations
so here what you can see is the
organization of the genome
the genome is about 30 000 nucleotides
long it has a number of different
proteins that are encoded in genes so
some genes are protein coding genes and
some are non-protein-coding
genes and what we want to do is find an
approach
that allows us to identify some
significant mutations that you can see
here
higher on the y-axis and start asking
questions about
the position on the genome their rate
of change and how can we associate this
with phenotype that ultimately could be
defined in multiple several ways
one way that we could characterize these
mutations is to start looking at how
these mutations are present on the 3d
structure
and so by understanding the 3d structure
and how it functions how it works
we can start asking questions about
whether we
understand what the potential impact of
this mutation
is on the interaction between the viral
host
the viral and host protein interaction
another way that we can
study this is to look at experiments
that show how genome
replication rate changes because of
these mutations so here's an example
from that kind of a study
you can essentially infect cells
and track the number of genomes and some
interpretation about that rate
and change is also important we can also
look at the type of change so we can ask
the question whether
a specific nucleotide changing to a
different nucleotide
is also going to result in a change in
the amino acid and what kind of a change
in the amino acid will it be
how evolutionary likely is that change
based on blossom scores
or how the physical chemical properties
of that specific change
could affect the interaction again with
the different proteins
so many different types of questions
that we can ask
but ultimately we need data and so to be
able to ask these kinds of questions i
think we can rely
first of all on scientific literature
that has been peer reviewed
and as you know there have been
thousands and thousands of publications
that have been coming out at a very
rapid speed
to tell us about novel insights about
the virus itself
individual proteins as well as the
interaction with the host
so what we want to focus on in this
program
is to take you through a number of
curated data sets and associated
publications
that will help us set a context for the
source code to emerging variants of
concern as well as some of the aspects
of vaccine design
drug design immune responses and other
factors that we think
are critical for understanding of how
this genomic data could be
useful and how it could offer new
insights
and important insights on the ground
about this effort that is ongoing
so one thing that we will talk about in
detail
is the organization of this spike
protein how the protein is organized
what do we know about the protein and
its function how can we ultimately look
at
the interaction between the viral
proteins
and the host proteins and ask questions
about specific regions
or functional domains that are important
in this process
of interaction in addition to that we
will then
take a look at the connection between
genomic data
as you can see here at the bottom and
the protein data that is available
to start asking the question about rate
of change
or mutation frequency that is observed
by
sampling specific groups of genomic
sequences
available in the public domain we will
also talk about
what are some of the potential selective
pressures that could explain
the emergence of specific mutations that
we observe so we will talk about
how antiviral drugs have been applied
how host immune responses might be
responsible
for specific changes and then try to
link that with
genomic information that we have about
specific types of
genomic uh genomes from the sonoroscope
to
databases so that we can link those
processes together and
ultimately ask the question of
specific mutation patterns
that could explain what we observe
in the drug treatment in the vaccine
treatment
in the host immunity patterns that are
already being studied
and so this information is also
important because
many early stage studies about
the immune responses that
are typical that are maybe abnormal
in acute infection or typical for
mild or asymptomatic infection can
really start putting together the
pieces of the puzzle for us to be more
informed about
how the interaction with the virus
happens in the course of the disease
how it affects outcomes and then start
using that information to understand
the specifics of these novel variants of
concern
so what's good about this is that there
are many publications already and these
publications come
with a lot of data sets that we can all
access
so ultimately we will not only look at
the reported
clinical genomic information that is
sampled from populations at different
time points but we will also take a look
at the more research data that is
available for
cell ion experiments animal experiments
as well as experiments done on
human cell lines and from downstream
patient studies so
we will talk about all of these aspects
in the program and try to link the
information that is being reported in
the specific types of publications
that also goes beyond these individual
point mutations but also talks about
deletions
and also multi-nucleotide changes that
are observed in these sequences which is
an important part of
information that is present in this
genomic data
but is not as often being being being
reported or
spoken about as prominently as we hear
about
these point mutations that might have a
consequence on
the protein structure so we will try to
look at the clinical side
and public health side but also we will
deep deeper
into the research side and try to
understand
what other types of variations and data
are present
and how should we utilize this
information
in the context of the genomic data that
everyone else is speaking about
so the program itself is a part of our
standard onyx logic bioinformatics
training program called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
but it has a much more specific and
in-depth focus on the source code 2
genomic data transcriptomic data
structural data and specifically with
this additional focus on the variance of
concern
and so we will introduce you to some of
the important
efforts that are being done throughout
this country in the us as well as
worldwide where there are specific
objectives to
leverage some of the genomic
surveillance for
informed decisions that could be done
by the u.s public and academic
institutions to really
address this challenge of novel variants
and to practice for the hands-on portion
of the program we will also talk about
specific analytical tools that will
include
consensus level analysis of variance
this is something that you can use in
your
research work this is something that you
can use to design
in a dependent bioinformatics project as
a citizen science or as a
scientist or as a student and also
something that you could leverage
to gain skills in all of these
aspects of analysis so what are the
specific
types of activities that we will do
we'll perform
consensus level of analysis of variance
so if you can imagine a
sequencing data set with specific depth
how do you identify the consensus of
where
those variants are present in all of the
reads or in the
larger proportion of the reads how to
detect
novel and prevalent variants which means
that we will look for specific positions
that have been reported
and find whether those are present or
not and at which
which proportion in given samples we
will
also look at sub-consensus and low
frequency variance which is an important
part
that we already talked about that
ultimately the emergence
of these prevalent variants starts with
a presence of low frequency mutations
that
eventually gain prominence and so that
really demonstrates the evolutionary
uh kind of struggle that happens between
the host
and the virus where the progeny of the
or original viral strain
divides up into these subclades and then
some clade becomes
more efficient at overcoming the immune
pressures ultimately becoming the
dominant strain so we'll look at that
sub-consensus
analysis and how to detect low frequency
variants
we'll also talk about low quality
samples one of the major things that is
ongoing right now is sampling data from
wastewater and taking data sets that
might not have
high level of accuracy like luminous
sequencing but instead oxford nanopore
sequencing
and how can we leverage that same data
using some quality control measures
to identify a variance of concern and
then we'll also
look at population scale tracking the
spread and emergence of variance
in densely populated areas so we'll take
some curated project examples for that
now as we go through these topics we
will also touch on some of the basic
concepts that you have to know
to be able to participate in such
studies and that includes an
understanding of different types of
sequencing techniques
understanding of data types and data
file formats we will also talk about
the specific details that allow us to
leverage quality control in a meaningful
way
we will talk about the process of
sequence alignment based on different
types of data like
fast q or fasta files we'll study
specific types of protocols that will
give us a better sense
of how data is generated and what types
of steps
are needed to use that data in a
meaningful way
and then we'll actually go through some
examples
of wastewater sequencing and other types
of sequencing and
what are the sources and the outcomes
for each type of study
and we will introduce you to some
user-friendly tools
that are available on the tbi info
platform to perform
multiple types of bioinformatic
pipelines that
cover the phylogenetic analysis variant
calling gene expression and structural
biology aspects of bioinformatics
workflow that are important to know in
the context of such studies
so ultimately what that means is
building pipelines from
logical steps understanding how these
logical steps tied
together and knowing what are the inputs
and outputs
so that your analysis is meaningful and
reproducible
for example one of the exam one of the
useful
kind of views i think that has been on
everyone's mind
is how do we identify the origins
of source code 2 in terms of zonotic
transmission and so
here we will turn to some of the
published data sets
and published papers that help us use
the logic
behind viral emergence and biology
and bioinformatics methods that allow us
to study
similarity between sequences to ask
questions about
the potential or the likelihood of
zoonotic transmission between different
known species
on the other hand we will also look at
some of the well studied and known
examples
that show specific changes at the
nucleotide level and the amino acid
level
to really understand how we can come to
conclusions
that have been reported in the public
domain
and this mutation the 614 gene mutation
that was well studied and i think well
understood
has really become a great example of how
we can
link the phylogenetic information
the specific variant calling information
that we can focus on
and the biological understanding of its
structural
and uh physical chemical interaction
properties
that we can translate into a meaningful
insight
about an identified mutation now this is
a single
mutation that we were talking about but
ultimately when you look at data
you are present with a lot of
information for
each individual sample that contains
many numbers of mutations
that are typically present in a given
sample and so one of the
challenges that you will come across is
how do i interpret this in a meaningful
way
knowing that many of these mutations are
either reported in literature and
databases or
not reported they could lead to
structural variation or not
lead to structural variation and then
how do we look at them
together complementary to each other
or detrimental to each other to
ultimately link it
to a specific phenotypic change
and so that's why all of these steps
these analytical steps are very
important so we'll
take some time to study pre-processing
and quality assurance
aspects of sequencing data and then we
will turn to
generating a report a meaningful report
based on
what is standard or kind of uh
something that people use in the
industry and the research
in general so this is an example of a
report from cosmos ied
a commercial report that one might get
from sending your data to a sequencing
lab
and we will perform the exact same
analysis
using tools in r so this is the report
that we will
generate using our scripts that take
process data from a pipeline and turn it
into a visual
and statistically significant report
that we can share with our collaborators
and partners
and so to produce this report we will
actually go through the code and learn
about some
useful packages that are typically used
for visualizing and performing
statistical analysis of data
including ggplot2 and some other
libraries for managing and working with
your
raw data including looking at the
specific positions
that are associated with a variant like
the us
or the uk sorry the uk south africa
brazil variants
including the delta and the delta plus
variants and so
this is going to be the culmination of
this program where you will be able to
sample some raw sequencing data load it
into the pipeline
produce the output of the pipeline and
then analyze that
whole pipeline output to generate a
report that you can share in a pdf
or a full report that you both
understand the statistical prevalence
the variance of concern but also their
biological relevance
now uh let's briefly go over some of the
program resources
so that everyone is clear on what is
going to be
included in this program but before that
i would like to launch a poll
and briefly ask you a few questions
about your background and your interest
in this program so i have launched a
poll and i would appreciate
if you could take a couple minutes to
answer some of these questions
so there's actually just two questions
here the first one
is about your background or your
designation
so are you a high school student
undergraduate student
bachelor's degree in college graduate
students
a master's degree in college
postgraduate phd
post-doc or research faculty or
management and administration and we use
this information to
continuously improve our programs and
make sure that the level of complexity
and
technical information that we provide in
the programs is appropriate for the
types of people that are interested in
these topics so thank you for those of
you that
are answering that question and then the
second
question is about your research
interests so
pine biotech is operating a number of
different programs
through the omixlogic training that we
provide
and those include infectious diseases
data science training machine learning
genomics proteomics epigenetics
transc transcriptomics aggregate
bioinformatics
and general bioinformatics so based on
your
responses here we will be able to adapt
our novel programs that are coming out
very soon and we will be
happy to share with you some details
about some of the upcoming
programs that we have starting this week
and in the next couple of months
so i'll just give it another couple of
minutes for everyone to be able to
finish the responses thank you again for
taking the time
okay and let's take another minute to
complete this poll please for all of you
that have
not completed the poll uh please take
just a couple of minutes
to finish your answers
okay thank you everyone
it looks like we have 70 percent
that have successfully completed the
poll
so thank you everyone for sharing that
information with us
i will end the poll for now and also
before we actually
continue with the program and resources
i would like to pass it on to dr
harpreet kohr who is going to be one of
the
mentors in the program to share a little
bit of information about her background
and how she will be able to help you
work with your data
and learn about these bioinformatics
methods over to you dr harpreet
thank you let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
my phd research was on biomarker
discovery for the diagnosis and the
prognosis of the liver cancer
using bioinformatics techniques
now let me give you some glimpse how
bioinformatics
can be helpful in identifying genomic
signatures
for identifying a specific signature for
a disease condition
so by taking an example from my phd
research work
so for example here in the first project
we use
large-scale transcriptomics data to
identify diagnostic biomarker panels
for the hepatocellular carcinoma which
is primary reverb pregnancy
so here we employed nearly 30 data set
containing 4000 sample to elucidate task
atomic biomarker
based on various machine learning
techniques
in the second part we focused on another
primary liberal malignancy which is
clangio carcinoma
so here we have identified three gene
based signature which is lamb c2 itc and
c2
to discriminate quantum carcinoma for
fcc and the normal samples in the next
part
we focused on uh another project where
we want to classify
and i want to predict tumor at an early
stage
so here we have identified 51 feature
based signature which include 30 rna
transcript and 21 methylation
cpg sites which can predict uh
hepatocellular carcinoma at an early
stage with
with nearly 80 percent accuracy
and we have developed all the prediction
model using the uh publicly available
data
and implementing various bioinformatics
techniques
so in my current role i am curriculum
developer and research consultant with
bind biotech
i am involved in designing uh research
projects as well as assisting the
participants in their analysis
and i also got the opportunity to
comment a number of the research follow
in their
research process which are depending
upon
based on the publicly available data
implementing various bioinformatics
techniques
so my current uh uh apart from the
uh projects on oncology then we also
focus
we have developed various projects based
on neuroscience
so apart from the graduate and
phd students then there are some of the
students
who are actually high school students
who completely research projects
based on the publicly available data and
using various bioinformatics tools that
are integrated
on t band for server on under pine
biotech
so my current research interest lies in
the application of the bioinformatics
and different human health aspects
although my primary research interest in
cancer
cancer genomics besides uh oncology
infectious disease and neuroscience are
the other
current research areas where i'm working
on currently
and i'm looking forward to being your
mentor in the upcoming
uh upcoming uh the upcoming program
so now i would like to pass this session
to sonalika so over to you sonalika
thank you so much dr harpreet for
telling us
about your research area now i would
like to welcome dr mohamed to take the
session details ahead over to your
doctor
um actually i think i will just do that
part i think when he did not
okay okay okay so
thank you again dr harpreet is going to
be
our mentor that will help all of the
participants
perform hands-on analysis and also take
on some of the session
sessions that we have planned to
introduce you to the specifics of the
program
how you can know about the topics that
we will cover
the schedule how to register all of that
information
i will actually share that information
with you so
if you could go with me to our site
called learnomicslogic.com and so for
this part of the session i would like to
ask you to actually make sure that
you are registered so this is the link
learn omixlogic.com
so if you could please let me know once
you
have registered on the site
i will show you how to access the
specific
tutorials and the synchronous materials
that you will
leverage throughout the program i will
also briefly demonstrate
how you can access the tbylinfo platform
and try the analysis
even in today's session so you get a
sense of what kind of hands-on
practical activities you will be going
through i will also show you
how to utilize the r code playground
so that you can practice some of the
code that we will be going through
for reporting and for tracking those
variants
and also i will then show you how you
can register
for the full program so please let me
know in the chat once you have been
registered if you're registered already
that's great just let me know in the
chat i will be looking for your answers
so once you are on this page
you need to go to login and on the login
screen
you can either log in you're using your
email address
or create an account right here so i
will
uh log in using my details
and once you are logged in you will be
seeing
your profile here where you can
understand
how the program actually works in both
asynchronous
mode and synchronous mode so for the
asynchronous mode really you have access
to
a number of different opportunities
for learning different courses we have a
number
of different courses that use data from
the public domain and show steps that
you can replicate
on your own and another section that you
will see here
is programs so the same is available on
the top
menu you can go to courses and search
for courses so we can search here for
example for
sars and you will find this project
right here
covered 19 origin and pathogenesis of
source code of two
or you can search for genomics
and find a course that introduces you to
the basics of genomics
how to align sequences what are
nucleotides what are amino acids what is
multiple sequence alignment
what does variant call it etc you'll
also find here
some course work on coding including
getting started with bioinformatics in
r or in python
okay so again this is the main area
for you to gain access to some
asynchronous materials
and you can search here most of these
courses are going to include
some basic material that you can get
started with
and then as you are convinced that this
is the right topic
for you the next stage is for you to
find some premium course work that
includes a little bit more hands-on
and a little bit more depth on the
various options for bioinformatics
analysis
and that comes with our starter
subscription so the starter subscription
is really affordable anywhere around the
world it's only ten
dollars a month and for that ten dollars
a month you gain access to all of the
coursework that is available here
even though most of it you could sample
completely free of charge
then we recommend moving on to the next
level which are the programs and so
today we have been speaking about
the source code 2 program so that
program
is going to start on july 12th so if you
search in the program kovit 19 genomics
and variant analysis
this is the program that we're going to
be starting now on my
screen you see what it looks like for
someone
that is already registered for the
program so let me
introduce a little bit what this works
like
or how this works like so as you can see
we have listed here the different
sessions
they start on july 12th and you will see
the topics listed right here with the
specific dates for them
when they will take place and you can
actually download all of this
information by clicking
clicking on this icon right here so
you can scroll through and see how we
will go through genomic data analysis
you will see how we will perform
the analysis in r and then you will see
what are the different
topics that will be covered in the
different sessions
down here below you will also see some
of the coursework that's going to be
included
and that coursework starts with a course
on introduction to bioinformatics
this is a free course that we recommend
everyone to take
and the course includes some important
information about the
applications of bioinformatics in a
variety of domains
so whether you are interested
specifically in source code
two or you're interested in other topics
like
transcriptomic data analysis metagenomic
data analysis
precision medicine and others you can
actually go through this course
and see the different applications that
will link it to
the next step of what you can do in this
process so after you've sampled some of
those courses you will actually get a
certificate to get that certificate
you need to have you need to
complete all of the sessions that we
have
in the program so there are going to be
10 sessions and
that will come with our point system
that you need to
uh let me empty the caches here that you
need to complete in order to gain the
certificate so the certificate comes
as a collaboration with a
university in haifa which is a
university
that is focused on development of
bioinformatics tools
that it seems somalia that somebody
forgot to upload the certificate here
but it's important to complete this
information
that is presented in the program to gain
that certificate
and then finally what you will find here
is
a slack channel that you can join to be
connected with the mentors and the
community
of those that are participating in the
program
and so if you join the program by
the start of the session which is going
to be july 12th
you will have full access to our mentors
and to the other participants and you
will see all of the interaction
happen in live sessions like today
as well as on a slack channel project
dedicated to the community as you can
see here we have different slack
channels for different programs and so
there it's an
effective way to track different
questions and technical issues
as well as to interact personally
one-on-one with those that are
members of this community
in addition to this i want to show you a
little bit
about the bioinformatics toolkit
that you will gain access to as a part
of your registration
so registering for this program will
give you access
to some important pipelines that are
going to be useful
as we go through the different examples
so let me show you what i mean by that
here and by the way after you have
registered you already have
a demo account on this platform this
platform is called t-bio info and it is
developed by the tower bioinformatics
research center
so here you can see how using different
types of
pre-made pipelines you'll be able to
understand better
what are the specifics of the logic
behind this analysis so how does that
work
will gain access to this interface in
the interface we have
informative pop-ups that allow you to
learn about each step of the analysis
including what type of data we are using
what is the logic behind each individual
step
and what are the specific outcomes of
this
step in the whole process of analysis
so performing these pipelines together
you will learn about how the specific
types of methods
that we are utilizing are helping us
gain
a full result that we can analyze in
the next step of the program so once you
have this result some of this result is
going to come
as a pdf that you can download and
explore visually
some information is going to be faster
files or even tables that you need to
know how to work with
so to do that i will give you just
one example of what you can do with some
of this information and to do that
let me show you a course called getting
started with bioinformatics in r
so this is a course in r
that will help you take faster files
and tables and learn how to manipulate
them to
produce visual outputs and the important
part of this
is that the practice comes right inside
the browser so
even before you install and configure
all of your libraries
you can already learn the code and try
it yourself
so for example in this brief lesson you
will
learn about different libraries to work
with faster files and sequences
and you will see how the specific steps
of this process
are explained very clearly in terms of
the coding
and then you'll be able to try yourself
simply
running this code in the browser itself
and looking at the output so
learning about the code and then knowing
how to perform the analysis itself
gives you the ability to try this and
then you will be given some assignments
that are going to be challenges for you
to
address as you try to write your own
code will help you reestablish
what is the logic but also how to
practically translate that logic
to coding skills in r so the program
itself will cover
these topics from biology to
bioinformatics
to then the application to specific data
sets that we've curated specifically for
this program
and we'll end with your ability to
perform the full analysis independently
and ultimately for those that are
interested we also
offer this as they transfer into our
research
fellowship program which is a specific
program that helps you
analyze the data and then generate
a report that you can share with others
including
writing a full report as you go through
the project steps
and to help you do that we actually have
a full project on how you can get
started
with a bioinformatics
research project
so this project this course will guide
you through the important steps of
finding a relevant topic by performing
literature review
identifying a data set in the public
repository that you can analyze
and then submit the full project and get
feedback
from our expert community so ultimately
when you go back to your personal
profile
you will be able to track your progress
and activity
using our tracker and the point system
you will also be able to see what
courses you have completed
and all the certificates for each
individual course are going to be
available
on your profile as well right here under
certificates
you will also see the progress of the
program and each session that you have
completed so you can also include
certificates for the program
itself and finally you will be able to
follow our process to get a project
completed during this program and post
it under your profile
so once your profile is complete and you
have reached at least
10 000 points by completing the
coursework assigned to you as a part of
this program or independently
then you will be able to submit a full
project and you first have to
learn about that project submission and
then
submit your project as an example to
all of the people that you would like to
share with that
illustrates how you have performed this
analysis so here
at the bottom of the home page you will
find some of those examples from our
previous participants
that have completed a project
i think this gives a brief overview of
what the program is going to be about
and hopefully everyone was able to
see the different aspects of the program
curriculum
the way that we will interact and the
different resources that are going to be
included
if you have any questions i would be
happy happy to answer those
at this time
and i do want to recommend for all of
you that are interested in the source
code 2
project we do have that project
available
that you can try out and see
what that content looks like learn about
some of the basics
as you get started kind of setting the
background for the whole
project context and then taking that
forward with
this guided mentor guided program if
you're interested to
learn more and also become proficient in
some of these methods of analysis
how do you access the arc course so all
you need to do is to register
on the omixlogic program uh platform
sorry
and you will see different courses as
they've shown
so you can actually go to the courses
tab
right here and search for r
i'm sorry
search for r
and get started with getting started
with bioinformatics
or if you want more advanced r you can
go to introduction to data science
now several of the projects that you see
here also
include specific codes in r for example
if you go to genomics as i mentioned
you will find here some course work in r
as well
so whenever you see r code that means
that the
course includes some practical coding in
r
thank you so much ilya so if you all
have any doubts you can ask now
or you can mail me at marketing at the
rate
i'm so sorry yes thank you so much
everyone and
thank you elia for guiding us to the
session
and now i would like to ask if any one
of you have
any doubts you may ask now but if you
would want to address them later you can
mail me at
marketing at the a fine dot bio or mohit
either a fine dot bio and we would be
there to guide you through
your enrollment thank you so much
everyone for
being a part of the webinar today and
we're looking forward to your
participation in the
sessions and then learn together thank
you